if future humans find a way to live for
thousands of years would that lead to a
massive overpopulation on whichever
Planet they
inhabit well chances are if they make it
possible to live that long they will
probably succeed in optimizing their
existence before that their civilization
would undoubtedly be a lot more
efficient than ours the reason being is
that they could be centuries if not
Millennia ahead of us in evolutionary
terms future humans would be a lot
smarter and they'd have better
technology to maximize their space and
live in densely populated worlds without
producing the same high levels of
pollution that we do on Earth in fact
you could bet that future humans
wouldn't just have better technology
they'd be technology